I hope you like memes,
or the next few minutes
will get very awkward.
(Laughter)
Memes are our internet's lingua franca.
So as a video game scholar,
but also a geek,
I will borrow them to talk about something
you might probably have heard about.
The metaverse.
Dam-dam-dam-dam.
(Laughter)
I'm sorry, I don't have
the license for that sound.
I know, I know.
Sci-fi fans will be leaving
comments on this video:
“The metaverse is not a new idea.”
In fact, as a TED premiere,
I want to showcase my research
on 30 years of the metaverse,
from its inception
to its current trajectory.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
That's right, the metaverse
is already on fire,
and we even have not built it yet.
That's efficiency.
How can this happen?
Think of the metaverse as a Frankenstein
made of different parts
of current internet
and digital technologies.
Now with 3D visuals and touch.
Between our physical
reality and virtual reality,
there are different layers of mixed
and augmented reality,
where physical and digital objects blend.
The metaverse will be somewhere
across this spectrum
that I call "the reality gradient."
But we shouldn't let
the 3D smoke and mirrors
distract us from the fact
that the metaverse is the internet,
and as such,
it will inherit the worst traits
of its current business models.
With premium access to our bodies,
VR headsets and sensors can extract
huge amounts of involuntary data
that we can't control,
like heartbeats or blinks.
This will get even worse
with neurotechnology,
allowing to read and modify our brains
creating a capitalism
of cognitive surveillance.
We certainly don’t want the metaverse
to become the bad sequel to the internet.
So how do we fix it
even before we build it?
By avoiding repeating
past internet mistakes.
Understanding why we're building it,
who can seize control of it
and what makes it different.
Huge questions and little time.
So let's focus on one key ingredient
for metaverse success:
connection.
As a scholar,
connection means that the metaverse
needs an architecture
linking all the metaverses together
in a way that we can travel across them.
Seems easy because jumping websites
is already an internet feature.
But that is because we don't carry
our digital belongings with us.
You can't take your
Instagram likes to TikTok
or your Roblox avatar to Fortnite.
To achieve that, we need
content portability,
which is a very difficult
engineering task,
one that requires an object to function
and look consistently across different
software environments.
But guess what?
It's also a lawyering problem
because you need
a complex structure of contracts
to legally copy a digital object.
Just between ourselves,
let me tell you a little
intellectual property secret.
Our digital goods are treated differently
from their tangible counterparts.
Instead of ownership,
we have a license to use them,
craftily limited by terms of service.
In the physical world,
something called “copyright exhaustion”
allows us to resell our goods.
But courts don't agree
if that applies to digital content.
And without this digital exhaustion rule,
exiting one metaverse will be like
going through very strict customs,
one that will confiscate
all your possessions
if you want to get through.
So connection in the metaverse
means interoperability.
A coherent system of legal
and technical standards
for true decentralization.
NFTs and blockchain
can provide the technical tools,
but they will never work
without the legal counterpart.
As an activist,
connection means
that the metaverse is the people.
The communities that will breathe life
and populate these worlds.
Without humanity, the metaverse
will be just a 3D ghost town.
But not everyone will be there
because we are not born equal
into the metaverse.
We are promised boundless worlds,
but in fact, we will be as free
as we can afford to pay.
We need to find ways to create
an inclusive metaverse,
one that keeps the best things
of humanity online:
kindness, creativity, cat memes.
This is not wishful thinking.
Kindness is a power house.
There are initiatives like Leyline
creating a blockchain proof of good deeds
or charity marathons
like Games Done Quick.
A game about sending
anonymous letter to strangers
might seem like a recipe for disaster,
but against all odds,
over one million letters
full of kindness were shared.
People want to do good.
And now we have the technical means
to escalate it to unprecedented levels.
The metaverse may still
be a work in progress,
but that means we still have room
and a chance to influence
what it will become...
open, accessible and inclusive.
It's not every day that humanity
has the chance to create a new reality.
So my invitation to you:
let's make it a good one.
Thank you, read you in the comments.
(Applause)